congressman Louie Gohmert was that
today's hearing you're about to hear
from him watch as Gohmert questions
Muller and that colloquy quickly turns
into sniping watch and if somebody knows
they did not conspire with anybody from
Russia to affect the election and they
see the big Justice Department with
people that hate that person coming
after him and then a special counsel
appointed who hires dozen or more people
that hate that person and he knows he's
innocent
he's not corruptly acting in order to
see that justice is done what he's doing
is not obstructing justice he is
pursuing justice and the fact that you
ran it out two years means you
perpetuated injustice as time has
expired the witness may answer the
question I take your question
congressman Louie Gohmert of Texas joins
us now congressman thanks for coming on
so you were there you spoke to the
former Special Counsel what was your
assessment of his condition of what he
said after talking to him well he is
older he's lost a rung or two on the
ladder but I was telling our guys early
on right after he started there's no
question his staff has been telling him
if you mentioned the report he's going
to ask you which volume which page he's
going to take up as much of your five
minutes as he can you know taking his
time gee what was that so I thought some
of it was an act some of it you know
he's just a older gentleman but that
does not excuse him putting this country
through hell as a special prosecutor
dragging this thing out I don't know if
you were aware but back last summer was
on with harris faulkner and she was
saying well Rudy Giuliani say
and he's going to be done for the end of
the summer he doesn't want to let the
election I said he doesn't know motor
like I do this guy's going to keep this
thing going as long as he can and he's
certainly not going to end it before the
2018 election I knew the guy knew he
wouldn't do that he would probably have
continued if we hadn't had a strong
Attorney General come in and see that he
had nothing after two years this is my
speculation but I think Wiseman had been
left to his own purposes he would have
kept going on and on so just clarify
something in Congress so you're saying
that from what you know of the
information he gathered he could have
wrapped this up before the midterm
election of 2008 year yeah he was
careful to say he wasn't going to answer
when he knew that there was no
conspiracy collusion what everyone
called but law calls it conspiracy he
wouldn't say but it was clear he knew
early on and in fact we all knew way
back over a year ago that there was
nothing there on the conspiracy with the
Russian agents that it was a bunch of
garbage he could have ended this back
then but he chose to effect an election
it was also clear from the hearing today
that Weissman must have been the driving
force in all of this exactly exactly and
that I think I think that that's been
clear for a long time but it was crystal
clear today congressman thank you for
that good touch thanks for your clarity
you've seen it all along